[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de 7,8 l'hebdo 26 minutes pour
revenir sur l'actualité de la semaine
dans les yvelines
au sommaire de ce vendredi 13 décembre
la commune de poissy accueille le
nouveau centre d'entraînement du paris
saint germain
la présentation a été faite cette
semaine l'académie de versailles a lancé
lundi son plan pour la laïcité à l'école
formation et un accompagnement du
personnel et promotion de ces valeurs de
la république aux élèves
la rectrice charline avenel nous le
présente reins des caméras piéton pour
les pompiers les premières conclusions
de l'expertisé de l'incendié du siaap
est une récompense pour l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines
nous pouvons notre retour hebdomadaire
de l'actualité dans votre département
le projet est attendu par les supporters
du psg depuis de nombreuses années le
futur centre d'entraînement va enfin
voir le jour le site avec tous les
équipements dernière génération sera
construit sur la commune de poissy la
presse à la présentation a été faite
mercredi les détails des avec michael et
demi d'euros c'était l'un des moments
phare du salon de l'immobilier
d'entreprise le paris saint germain a
présenté ce mercredi 11 décembre son
futur centre d'entraînement
le site sera implanté sur le nord de la
commune de poitiers à 25 minutes du parc
des princes d'abord c'est un projet qui
valorise le territoire avant de
valoriser la seule ville de poitiers à
voir le paris saint germain sur 75
milliard avec 1000 emplois pendant la
durée des travaux
2 millions d'euros de taxes annuelles
pour la communauté urbaine
oui c'est juste c'est juste exceptionnel
faut bien comprendre que une marque
comme le psg savoir quelle est la
implanté dans les yvelines pour un
retentissement international
c'est une publicité à zéro euro
donc c'est fait quelque chose de
formidable le site est encore un terrain
vague mais les fouilles archéologiques
ont débuté les premiers travaux seront
invisibles au printemps à terme le
centre comprendra les équipements
ultramodernes avec un dojo un terrain de
handball un stade de 5000 places et 17
terrains de football dont un couvert
on n'a pas forcément cette ambition on
va tâcher d'être dans les meilleurs
c'est notre volonté d'être dans les
meilleurs donc on a un travail qu'on a
réalisé en toute humilité il ya encore
des très grands clubs qui sont présents
on veut partie des très grands clubs on
va tâcher d'être meilleur la livraison
définitive est à l'heure actuelle
programmée pour l'été 2022 le coût total
des travaux devrait avoisiner les 220
millions d'euros
le 9 décembre c'était la journée
nationale de la laïcité
à cette occasion l'académie de
versailles a lancé son nouveau plan pour
la laïcité à l'école
charline d'avesnelles bonjour bonjour
madame vous êtes la rectrice de
l'académie de versailles
alors concrètement pourquoi ce plan ce
plan il a d'abord parce que la laïcité
quelque chose de très important c'est
bien le plus précieux de la république
et de l'école à quoi ça sert au fond de
la laïcité à l'école
eh bien ça sert à permettre la liberté
de conscience de tous les enfants leur
permettre d'apprendre de manière libre
en ayant le droit de croire ou de ne pas
croire
et puis surtout c'est un puissant
ferment de la vie en commun donc au fond
la laïcité c'est ce qui permet à la fois
d'être libre et de vivre en communauté
donc c'est la raison de son importance
alors il ya trois grands plans dans ce
pot dans ce plan trois grands points l
arrivée une formation renforcée du
personnel une équipe valeurs de la
république pour accompagner au quotidien
la liesse était abordé dans les classes
au sein des programmes et même au sein
d'activités
comment cela va-t-il se dérouler alors
vous avez cités en effet les grands
points du programme
le premier élément c'est la formation
nos élèves ont besoin d'enseignants
d'adultes de directeur d'école qui
soient formées mais fort mais ça veut
pas seulement dire être au fait de
l'état du droit qui est par ailleurs
parfois un petit peu compliqué à
appréhender
il faut connaître le droit connaître les
règles et puis par ailleurs il faut
pouvoir très concrètement se représenter
les choses
que fait-on si par exemple quelqu'un
tracts à l'entrée d'une classe du
prosélytisme sur un sujet voilà donc il
s'agit vraiment d'avoir des éléments à
la fois théorique et très très concret
le deuxième élément est bien il s'agit
d'avoir une équipe qui est déjà en place
qui est déjà au travail auprès de tous
les intervenants de tous les personnels
pourquoi pas des familles s'ils ont des
questions si l'on défait à remonter et
donc ceci appelle il ya une équipe qui
est disponible en permanence pour
résoudre les situations les plus
délicates
et puis parfois donner des conseils sur
la manière
nourri le dialogue avec les personnes
concernées et enfin qui est dans cette
équipe dans cette équipe il ya des
référentes de l'académie des inspecteurs
des directeurs d'établissements donc et
une quinzaine de personnes qui sont
prêts à répondre qu'ils sont à la fois
l'échelle académique et à l'échelle
départementale au plus près du terrain
et donc sont des personnes qui sont
formés et à même de répondre à ces
questions
et le troisième point c'est que la
laïcité dans les classes la laïcité dans
les classes alors en effet cette semaine
c'était la journée de la laïcité j'ai pu
voir ce que portaient nos professeurs
dans les écoles dans les collèges dans
les lycées je suis allé à arpajon voir
quelque chose d'absolument magnifique
que les élèves avaient fait une
exposition sur la laïcité dont il était
vraiment capable d'expliquer les
fondements le fonctionnement avec
beaucoup de beaucoup de richesses par
exemple à versailles
l'école des condamines a fait un arbre
de la laïcité a fait des chansons sur le
sujet donc voilà ça vient compléter les
enseignements qui sont de toute façon
prévu dans le cadre des programmes
scolaires et c'est important parce que
ce sont à ce moment là les élèves qui
très souvent se saisissent eux mêmes de
ces sujets et sont les meilleurs
ambassadeurs de la vérité alors un
chiffre 65 atteinte au principe de
laïcité signalé en 2018 2019
qu'est ce qu'une atteinte au principe de
laïcité est alors une atteinte au
principe de laïcité ça peut être des
faits très divers ça peut être par
exemple une jeune fille qui rentre dans
une école et qui refuse de mettre son de
d'enlever son voile ça peut être par
exemple une difficulté pour aller à
l'enseignement de gymnastique
parce que ça n'est pas cohérent avec ses
propres croyances et c'est quelque chose
de difficile pour la personne ça peut
être par exemple le fait de tracter pour
une aumônerie dans un lycée au fond
c'est tout acte qui contrevient la
licité parce qu'il est un acte de
prosélytisme
au sein de l'école et pourquoi
l'académie de versailles a souhaité
parler de ce sujet et le lancer un plan
ici alors d'abord c'est une des
priorités nationales faire vis la
laïcité c'est une très bonne manière
d'avoir un climat social un climat
serein un climat scolaire serein et
c'est ce qui fait réussir nos élèves
donc c'est à la fois une
une dimension nationale une priorité
nationale et puis parce que j'ai
considéré que notamment sur le volet de
formation nos enseignants avaient
vraiment besoin d'être confortés dans
leur pratique professionnelle et sur les
formations en termes de calendrier ça
commence quand et ça va continuer
combien de temps alors l'équipe laïcité
je l' ai déjà dit elle et elle est déjà
en place
les événements dans les écoles ils ont
déjà lieu et on en a eu vraiment de
jolis exemple que cette semaine la
formation ça va commencer dès le début
d'année dès le mois de janvier on va
commencer par former les formateurs pour
que eux mêmes puissent se répartir
ensuite les formes et les directeurs
d'école les inspecteurs les enseignants
tout au long du semestre qui arrivent
nous allons changer de thématiques pour
aborder la mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites dans
l'enseignement le plus gros de la
mobilisation s'est tenue le 5 décembre
avec des pourcentages de grévistes
conséquent dans l'académie 55 % dans les
écoles 53 % dans les collèges 37 37 %
dans les lycées généraux et
technologiques et 23 % dans les lycées
professionnels
ce même jour un groupe d'une vingtaine
d'enseignants s'est mobilisée à
guyancourt devant la direction
académique des yvelines
un lieu symbolique pour montrer leur
désaccord avec le projet de loi et mardi
matin rassemblement s'est déroulé devant
les locaux de l'université versailles
saint quentin en yvelines à guyancourt
à l'appel d'une intériorisation une
quinzaine d'étudiants professeurs et de
personnel de l'établissement étaient
mobilisés contre le projet de loi mais
aussi contre la précarité étudiante
ces personnes se sont ensuite rendus
devant lui ai fait faire des sciences de
la santé à montigny le bretonneux ou
levesque lui voté son adhésion en tant
que membre à l'université paris saclay
propos recueillis par michael et demi
d'euros patrick jacq t dixmude la
fonction publique qui est directement
impactée par ce projet de réforme
puisque effectivement sur le calcul des
pensions va y avoir une différence très
importante qui est estimé à au moins 20%
par rapport au système actuel et que par
ailleurs on subit aussi un projet de loi
de transformation de la fonction
publique qui va complètement redéfinir
les modalités de représentation mais
aussi le
en principe les missions du service
public alors lui vécu dans certaines
filières ont reporté certains examens à
cause des grèves
sharyn avenel et les la situation
actuelle en termes de manifestations et
les prévisions à venir je parle
notamment du mardi 7 décembre alors cité
les chiffres de la grande journée de
grève aux alentours de 50 % dans le
premier degré avec du système minimum
d'accueil qui a pu être le plus possible
être mise en place
on a été sur la deuxième journée de
grève plutôt aux alentours de 10%
la semaine prochaine est difficile de se
prononcer mais d'autres qu'eux on aura
en aura aussi de la grève et puis
surtout des enseignants qui sont mises
en difficultés pour rejoindre parfois
lors leur établissement comment on gère
ces mobilisations au sein de l'académie
alors il via le système le service
minimum d'accueil qui se fait au gré
d'un dialogue avec avec les mairies qui
marche sur l'ensemble du territoire
on essaye de donner le plus possible
d'informations à l'échelle de
l'établissement pour les parents pour
qu'ils sachent quelle est la situation
et puis et puis nous on est en situation
évidemment de pouvoir réagir
à chaque situation qui serait un peu
plus complexe à gérer au sein de
l'académie
c'est dans ce contexte que les élèves de
1re se prépare à affronter les épreuves
communes du contrôle continu du
baccalauréat de nouvelles formules
c'est cette dernière thématique que je
souhaiterais aborder avec vous chagrine
avesnelles pour rappel suite à la
réforme du bac les épreuves terminales
contre compte pour 60% les épreuves
communes de contrôle continu et 30% et
les bulletins de première et terminale
10 % de la note finale du bac et ses
épreuves communes débute en janvier
comment cela va-t-il se dérouler ça m'a
bien déroulée ça va bien se dérouler
parce que d'abord l'ensemble de la
réforme du lycée apporte beaucoup aux
enseignants et aux élèves
l'offre de formation est très riche sur
sur l'académie et dans les yvelines en
particulier les familles s'en sont
saisis les enseignants sont je crois
globalement satisfaits de leur emploi du
temps la rentrée donc tout se déroule
pas à pas et tout se déroule plutôt bien
parce que cette réforme elle est très
très très sa compagne ça va être le cas
et c'est le cas également pour les
épreuves dites de contrôle continu qui
vont compter pour 30 % de la note du
baccalauréat alors évidemment c'est une
transition
c'est une transition pour les
enseignants qui avaient l'habitude
d'avoir leur copie de les amener dans
leur cartable de corriger ces copies là
où il pouvait et on leur demande
d'utiliser des outils qu'ils ne
connaissent pas donc on les accompagne
et on ira à leur rencontre vraiment avec
les outils pour qu'ils ne soient pas
mises en difficulté et qu'ils puissent
profiter de ce qui va quand même
constitué pour une modernisation
vraiment importante et puis pour les
élèves est bien là aussi
c'est une transition donc j'ai pu
constater par exemple en allant au lycée
de marly-le-roi que les élèves étaient
souvent un peu stressé de ces épreuves
continue ils savent pas tellement
comment comment ça va se passer mais je
crois que leurs professeurs les
accompagnent leur montre de quelle
nature vont être les épreuves les y
prépare et puis là aussi pour les élèves
une fois qu'ils auront passé c'est
l'épreuve continue ils auront accès à
leur copie a posteriori qui pourront re
consultez donc voilà je crois qu'une
fois que on aura fait cette première
session est vraiment l'accompagnant très
très vivement
chacun pourra y trouver un grand
bénéfice pour conclure l'établissement
ils sont prêts les établissements ils
sont prêts on a des des chefs
d'établissement qui sont exceptionnels
qui sont en situation de pilotes
pédagogique de cette réforme de sa mise
en oeuvre
tout le monde est accompagner et former
donc nous serons prêts collectivement
voilà c'est une entreprise collective
mais j'ai confiance
on arrive à la fin de cet entretien
merci charyn damned est revenue sur
notre plateau je le rappelle vous êtes
rectrice de l'académie de versailles
on passe on reste de l'actualité de la
semaine
quelques semaines après la fin du
grenelle des violences conjugales le
journaliste de tv 78 grégory canale a
recueilli le courageux témoignage d'une
femme victime de violences elle est
actuellement hébergé par une association
et se reconstruit je vous laisse écouter
son témoignage
j'ai commencé comme je commence à
travailler le travail ça va donner un
petit peu courage et commence à parler
avec les jours mai 2010 neuf mois de
juillet il ya des violences qui m'a tapé
avec la porte de la voiture dans la rue
et ses lumières qui m'a trouvé paca dans
le local à celui qui m'a encouragé c'est
en fait c'est pas lui est permis mais
c'est la chape de la cabine qui m'a
donné
mignot et la plaine associations et j'ai
raconté mme associations et aussi que
j'étais folle ambiance et un policier
qui monte dans un bus ou sur mehdy matin
il faut porter plainte parce que si tu
as été envoyé à l'hôpital la prochaine
phase avec ce huitième l'intégralité de
ce témoignage est à retrouver sur notre
site internet et notre application
mobile et n'oubliez pas le numéro des
coudes gratuit le 39 19 le ministre de
l'intérieur christophe castaner l'avait
annoncé en juillet 2019
l'expérimentation de l'usaj de caméras
individuel par les sapeurs pompiers dans
le cadre de leurs interventions du
service d'incendié et de secours se sont
portés candidats à la phase
d'expérimentation dont les 10 78
reportage demain par ado et mathilde et
demi les sapeurs pompiers du service
d'incendié et de secours des yvelines
ont fait l'acquisition de 26 caméras
piétons elles sont déployées dans sept
centres d'incendié et de secours du
département dont la caserne de
versailles ce dispositif expérimental
est une première dans les yvelines
il ya un certain nombre de
de territoire dans les yvelines où des
pompiers sont peut-être parfois
davantage victime de prises à partie
personnelle cette caméra piéton est un
outil de lutte et de prévention contre
les agressions de sapeurs pompiers en
intervention
elles ont augmenté de 2 113 % en dix ans
l'objectif c'est de ramener le calme de
dissuader d'éviter de se faire agresser
en en essayant de faire en sorte que
l'individu qui vous menace ou qui vous
agressent verbalement voir qui vous
agressent physiquement et 8 de le faire
du fait qu'il va savoir qu'il va être
filmé les images et sons seront
conservées pendant six mois les caméras
piéton d'une autonomie de 12 heures
seront portés par un membre d'équipage
qui pourra opérer au déclenchement sur
sa propre initiative
si maintenant l'âge où on a pris par
erreur à puis la caméra se déclenche pas
par contre lorsqu'il appuie deux fois
c'est pour confirme en fait conclut un
saison délicate quand ça prend c'est
très intéressant
ces caméras permettront la collecte de
preuves pour identifier et poursuivre
les auteurs de l'agression
mais aussi améliorer la formation des
agents par les captations pour certains
pompiers est là avant tout un rôle de
dissuasion
c'est quelque chose de rassurant pour
notre sécurité cette phase
d'expérimentation des caméras piétons
durera jusqu'en février 2022
les pompiers qui seront présents en
plateau de cette fuite journal lundi
pour nous parler des dangers domestiques
en période de noël
six mois après l'incendié du siaap la
secrétaire d'état auprès de la ministre
de la transition écologique et solidaire
s'est rendu sur le site sinistré
elle a pu constater les dégâts et
prendre connaissance des avancées des
différents audits lors d'une commission
de suivi organisée par la préfecture des
yvelines
reportage de nicolas d'andré des débris
des escaliers des murs en ruines les
dégâts causés par l'incendié de la
station d'épuration d'achères le 3
juillet dernier
plus précisément sur l' usine c'est
naval de saint germain en laye du siaap
chargée de traiter les eaux usées
six mois plus tard les premiers éléments
émergent suite aux expertises sur les
causes de ce sinistre sur le cube quête
en maintenant son cul plus particulière
et visez donc quatre causes possibles
différentes tous d'origine électrique
donc on va patienter le temps que
l'espère d'une de l'assurance puisse
aller au bout de sa mission
actuellement une installation provisoire
fonctionne pour traiter les eaux usées
pour comprendre et tirer les
conséquences trois audits sont en cours
emmanuelle wargon secrétaire d'état
auprès de la ministre de la transition
écologique et solidaire est venu
constater les dégâts et échanger avec
les parties prenantes
on a lancé de façon très sérieuse toutes
les procédures permettant d'aller au
bout des causes est au bout de
l'amélioration des mesures de précaution
et de prévention
après il manquait un plan de prévention
et d'information des habitants qui sera
validée d'ici quelques jours
probablement d'ici la fin de l'année
et du coup ça permettra d'engager une
discussion plus structurée avec les
riverains sur quoi faire il faut
prévenir et mettent tout en oeuvre pour
que les mesures préventives de sécurité
empêche totalement je dirais une
catastrophe
c'est là-dessus véritablement qui vont
mettre le paquet pour éviter que l'on
passe au niveau des pays
c'est alex est trop tard une nouvelle
réunion de suivi doit avoir lieu fin
janvier début février avec les premiers
résultats des audits avec peut-être les
raisons de cet incendie sur ce site
industriel à montigny le bretonneux le
personnel de la petite enfance étaient
en grève lundi
une quarantaine de personnes s'est
réunie dans la matinée devant l'hôtel de
ville à l'appel de la cfdt
leurs revendications plus de personnel
selon les grévistes le manque d'effectif
conduirait à des conditions de travail
difficiles des agents au bord du burn
out de la sécurité des enfants qui ne
seraient pas assurés de manière optimale
de son côté la mairie ne conteste pas le
manque d'effectif mais accuse un déficit
de recrutements liés à une pénurie sur
le secteur de la petite enfance depuis
deux ans en ile de france
elle indique que 80 commission de
recrutement donné lieu cette année à
trente et une embauche
une délégation syndicale a été reçue par
le maire elle estime avoir été écouté
mais n'est pas satisfaite pour autant
des propositions de la municipalité une
nouvelle action est en réflexion
ouah gaspillage économie circulaire
présenté le 27 septembre a été adoptée
elle est actuellement examiné à
l'assemblée nationale
martha dos idrac sénatrice des yvelines
était la chef de file d'une raie
autour de cette loi elle a notamment
abordé les déchets et le plastique avant
de se rentre sur le terrain
reportage de manon par aldo et patrick
jacques de dixmude martha d'ci drague
sénatrice des yvelines et rapporteur de
la loi gaspillage économie circulaire a
organisé une réunion autour de cette loi
adoptée au sénat est examiné à
l'assemblée nationale une loi autour
d'un certain nombre de dispositifs qui
concerne plus spécifiquement les élus
locaux et les territoires en premier
chef
ce sera essentiellement autour bien
évidemment des déchets et des dépôts
sauvages puisqu'on a un vrai sujet dans
notre département mais également sur
tout ce qui concerne les plastiques en
hors foyer les usages que l'on fait
selon les régions nous n'avons pas
toujours les mêmes codes couleurs pour
les poubelles le texte permettra
d'uniformiser cela un objectif partagé
il ne s'agira pas pour les collectivités
d'investir dans de nouvelles poubelles
parce que vous imaginez le coude
l'idée c'est de trouver un code qu'il
soit partagé par nous tous et qui soit
le même dans toute la france
martha de cidre ac est revenu sur les
bouteilles en plastique le logo inscrit
dessus le point vers les usagers pensent
en grande majorité qui signifie que le
produit acheté recyclables ces faux qui
ne font pas induire nos consommateurs en
erreur
il faut leur donner la bonne information
et c'est le sens de deuxième logo dont
on a parlé ce matin qui est le tri man
et chivu stipule très clairement si un
produit doit être triés et donc
potentiellement recyclé derrière martha
dos idrac s'est rendu à l'usiné france
plastique de recyclage de limay où sont
reconnaissables des bouteilles de notre
usage quotidien
le recyclage des produits de
consommation courante c'est un des
volets de la loi gaspillage et que de
lui circulaire
ces plastiques vont évidemment être
introduit dans l'installation qui est à
côté de nous qu'ils vont subir tout un
système tout un procès ce qui de déchets
plastiques tel que nous le voyons ici
vont devenir en fait des paillettes qui
vont être incorporées dans des produits
finis et qui vont de nouveau être
réinjectés dans le commerce le but avoir
une durée pour ses produits la plus
longue possible en l'airé introduisant
de nouveaux dans une filière qui n'est
pas forcément celle du produit d'origine
le gouvernement affiche un objectif de
100 % de plastique recyclé pour 2025
une cérémonie de don d'ordinateurs
premier événement du genre organisé
lundi par le conseil départemental des
yvelines à versailles
la collectivité a souhaité mettre en
valeur des élèves méritants 85
collégiens issus des réseaux d'éducation
prioritaire ont reçu des ordinateurs
portables qui pour vous garder pour la
suite de leurs études
des élèves de 6e et de 5e des collèges
de carrières sous poissy chanteloup les
vignes limer les mureaux manque la jolie
sartrouville et trappes les témoignages
du cros de mme hanoune faraldo pour
choisir les enfants nous nous en sont
adressés directement aux principaux des
collèges concernés
on leur demande de choisir les élèves
particulièrement méritants de ce soir
par leur comportement leur participation
à la vie citoyenne par leur progression
des élèves qui méritent d'être
récompensés encourager je suis content
et on m'a dit du jeu lui méritait donc
je suis encore plus contente
dans ces cas-là et bac il ya des gens
qui pensent à nous quand on fait tout le
monde tous nos efforts
je vais bien travailler de ce soir je
vais faire d exploser et ça va beaucoup
m'aider pour l'année prochaine et pour
mon avenir je suis choqué je pensais pas
cette année que j'aurais eu son cadeau
autre cérémonie cette fois au sein du
simi le salon de l'immobilier
d'entreprise trois jours d'événements au
palais des congrès à paris saint quentin
en yvelines ni a reçu un prix celui de
l'innovation urbaine
une récompense interdépartemental remise
par les yvelines et les hauts-de-seine
cette distinction souligne le travail du
territoire sur le thé pop
les déploiements numérique dans les
structures scolaires on écoute le
président de l'agglomération au micro de
miguel et demi d'euros c'est
certainement en france la première fois
que 12 ville s'associent pour
transformer leur école un niveau aussi
élevé je vous rappelle que on améliore
le plaisir d'apprendre avec cette
méthode et on améliore le plaisir
d'enseigner pour les profs
et en fait on augmente la confiance en
soi des enfants
on augmente
la créativité chez les enfants et leur
autonomie un peu de sport avec une
équipe à suivre après sa victoire au 8e
tour de la coupe de france face à wihr
dimanche dernier le tirage au sort a
désigné granville comme futur adversaire
pour ce 32e de finale le match aura lieu
début janvier à domicile qu'on ville qui
évolue une deuxième une division au
dessus du club versailles et cela fait
une dizaine d'années qui n'avait pas
atteint ce stade de la compétition
un mot de volley ball le vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
serait en négociations avancées pour
organiser une rencontre de première
division ligue à
le match se déroulerait courant mars
avril dans la structure le dossier
serait en phase de finalisation et
pourrait concerner deux équipes de haut
du tableau on parle de tours et de paris
l'office il est l'officialisation
devrait intervenir courant janvier et
maintenance hors des frontières
yvelinoise pour notre rubrique en ile de
france
[Musique]
c'était un chantier de longue haleine
après quatre années de travaux le
prolongement de l'a 16 vers l'échangeur
de la croix verte vient d'être mise en
service
il devrait permettre une circulation
plus fluide dans la région les
précisions de nos confrères via grand
paris enfin le prolongement de l'a 16
vers la francilienne est ouvert à la
circulation l'aboutissement de près de
quatre ans de chantier
désormais le trafic devrait être plus
fluide dans cette zone du département
ce projet a permis d'éliminer un des
gros points noirs de circulation en
ile-de-france qui est rond point de la
croix verte qui a désormais complètement
disparu et permet des connexions
directes en fait maintenant entre la
plateforme aéroportuaire de roissy et
celle de beauvais et des connexions est
ouest à haut débit 100 au bouchon l'a16
connecté à la francilienne devient un
axe central entre le val d'oise le grand
paris et les hauts de france pour en
arriver là il a fallu des travaux de
longue haleine débuter en 2016
autre objectif du projet réduire le
trafic sur l'ancienne nationale une qui
traversaient les communes de montsoué
maffliers il ya eu plus de trois
kilomètres de rock de mise aux normes de
la nationale une existante
donc on l'a mise aux normes
autoroutières il ya eu une section
autoroutière 9 sur un peu plus de 3 km
également
et il ya eu surtout le grand
réaménagement de la croix verte de la
connexion de la cèze avec la
francilienne le réaménagement de la
croix verte était une étape clé du
chantier la suppression du giratoire a
causé de nombreuses fermetures de routes
aujourd'hui les usagers peuvent souffler
mes deux derniers ajustements restent à
faire l'ascèse doit encore être relié à
la départementale 300 une en direction
de paris et la liaison entre les huit
rond-point de l'échangeur de la croix
verte doit être achevée fin des travaux
prévue en février 2020
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
nous avoir suivis pour week-end sur télé
[Musique]